the horrors of sir david amos's final
moments are captured in the panicked
voices around him
please please quick now the man is
wielding a knife and he's telling me
he's wearing he's killed he killed dave
again most at belfast methodist church
this is yvonne eves a constituent who
had an appointment with the mp that
afternoon making the 999 call that
alerted police to the attack
you see he's always still in real time
see how can you see how big the knife is
yes it's um it's a it's a garden knife a
big kitchen carving knife and we can't
always try to get it off and he won't be
threatened myself there's threatened
tall people here
he wants to get shot apparently he wants
to be a hero he wants the police to come
and shoot him okay we've got lots and
lots of you to come through okay
wherever all that is phone to be though
okay where are they all right
the jury were played cctv footage that
appears to show ali harbi ali leaving
his home in north london that morning
and walking to gospel oak station he
passes members of the public and boards
a busy train to barking station
there on the platform he smiles as he
interacts with a stranger who's out of
shot
he arrives in lyon c in essex an hour
and a half before his appointment with
sir david
as he nears the church
ali appears lost
passing along dre
he wanders to an intersection
but later turns back and heads in the
direction of the church
it's a journey the prosecutions say he'd
researched days before
the court was shown this email ali
allegedly sent to sir david amos
requesting an appointment
it claims ali will be moving to the area
and says as someone interested in
christianity i have seen many churches
in my area losing attendances and
struggle with upkeep i wanted to know if
the situation in south end is similar
in the days leading up to the incident
it's alleged ali harbi ali made a number
of internet searches including sir david
amos's political views and his voting
history on the middle east conflict and
searching for a muslim burial ground and
looking at a page titled what should a
person do if they feel like their death
is approaching
ali habi ali denies murder and denies
planning acts of terrorism
the case continues tomorrow
ashnahara nags sky news at the old
bailey